our next guest is one of the most
respected names in business i love
business i don't know why i was like
born a total hippie but i love business
and she turned a thousand dollar
enterprise into a 5
billion dollar brand
making her the queen of real estate i
don't know if you know this but most
people would rather serve zillow than
have sex there's studies about i'm just
saying so she chose the right field she
invested in over 80 businesses on her
emmy award-winning shark tank show and
she's here today
i am such an uber fan
i mean you do two of my favorite things
real estate and business well why don't
we exchange seats
for a whole week i i just want to
exchange numbers and ask you about your
work-life balance too forget about that
call somebody else oh good that's an
honest answer yeah yeah um
i was i love you on social media thank
you you're you are and very interesting
i love it like i'm wacky
well i'm myself on social media who
cares right me too
freedom freedom
um actually i was i follow you on social
and i saw this comment that you did on
your instagram post
um and uh we have a image of it right
here
um
dude with sign i love that guy let us
mark text as unread i love him too yeah
he spot on that guy every time he went
from you know a few followers to
millions upon millions upon millions
very fast faster than most accounts i've
ever seen in social media life because i
think people just loved what he was
doing and also people would uh identify
with every one of his messages
but they never paused to think about it
he's his messaging was so similar like
let us
mark tex as unread i didn't think about
that till i saw inside the wow i could
avoid all the people i want to avoid i
could just not open those texts make a
pile of procrastination and get back to
them when i'm in a good mood i was
saying this guy's got a great idea and
everybody responds to him that way well
it's funny because he happens to be
right here in our audience
[Applause]
[Applause]
when you get old enough i want to marry
you
seth how are you today very happy doing
pretty well you never smile in any of
these i know it freaks a lot of people
out i think you've got good teeth yeah
you got good teeth show the teeth thank
you a good thing no i'm serious i have
to let not meet business you know
i was going to say is that it you want
people to know like you're convicted
honestly i think i just did it the first
couple times and i saw a lot of comments
of people thinking it was funny like wow
he's so serious and just kevin gone
and are you serious in real life not at
all
i'm also a little wacky hey do you make
any money on this i've always been i'm
sorry it's like you could edit it out
right no go
i do make money i was able to quit my
job and that's my full time i need to
make money on it
reach out to me friends reach out to me
and i'll hold a sign that you know says
something about their brand i'm holding
signs seems like an easy living it's a
not a bad one yeah seth you are
truly
one of a kind and everybody's picking up
what you're putting down you are so
awesome
i love you i do
thank you so much for coming today thank
you happy to be here i'm so happy for
the empire you're building okay so now
you've invested millions of dollars into
companies but i really love what you
look for in the people you invest in
will you tell me about that
i don't look for really smart people
honestly i i look for people that are
soulful that totally believe in what
they're doing i'm also looking for
someone who's had struggles you know we
get a lot of rich kids on shark tank
pitching they have funds from their
family and friends nothing's wrong with
that but i love to see a guy who had a
father who was drunk talks about it and
so there's nothing better than
individual who wants to show the world
they could do it who when the world
thought they couldn't whoever the world
was
and so then i get an entrepreneur who's
on fire and stays on fire not just like
he's excited at first or she's excited
first but they stay on fire because
they're on a mission to prove and those
are always the businesses i make the
money on even if it's a stupid product i
make money on it because of the
individual i love that i don't think
i've really heard
anyone in business say that and i'm
telling you as someone who has been
broken several times throughout their
life
um and i'm sure most of us have been
because that is the journey of a life to
hear that you are rooting for those
people thank you barbara thank you for
being who you are
seriously
everybody's going for something else yes
is there ever been an opportunity that
you missed that you kicked yourself for
oh
sure know what the first one that comes
to mind of course was that stupid smiley
sponge that laurie brought into what was
it scrub daddy went
and
and uh and it does it did well right
when i saw it i thought who the heck
would want a smiley face on this sink
well eight
eight hundred thousand people wanted
and laurie made a fortune but then i you
know you never know what's gonna strike
on shark tank we act smart but we don't
know what we're doing but on shark tank
another one came in two crazy guys
brothers fun-loving and they pitched a
oversized blanket with a hood and they
said they didn't know what they would
sell it for they hand made it they
didn't know where they would make it in
fact they didn't know anything and i
bought it because i thought they were a
lot of fun and we've made 400 million
dollars
go figure i have one upstairs in pink
yeah i have a comfy too
[Music]
you